malaysia's Transport Minister  Hishammuddin Hussein on one of the first  military planes searching the Malacca  Straits for the missing Boeing 777  that's the region Malaysia's military  now says the plane had its last radar  contact before vanishing this supports  the theory that the pilots turned around  on their planned route to Beijing but  why this should have been the case is  still unclear four days after the plane  disappeared Interpol initially suspected  a terrorist link to to illegal  passengers now investigators believe the  two Iranians on board simply were  illegal migrants heading for Europe we  know that once these two individuals  arrived in kuala lumpur on a twentieth  of februari they boarded flight 370  using different identities some  relatives of the 153 Chinese passengers  still missing have now arrived in Kuala  Lumpur they know that the chances of  good news are dwindling by the hour